If you're learning a language, practicing with
native speakers is the fastest way to become fluent.
Take effective online lessons
with native teachers on italki.
Buy your first lesson and get your second lesson free.
Link in description.
Hello everyone. Welcome to the Langfocus channel
and my name is Paul.
Today I'm going to talk about the Kurdish language.
Where is Kurdish spoken?
Well, that's an interesting question.
Kurdish is the language of the Kurdish people, an ethnic
group who do not have their own independent country.
They mostly live in the Kurdistan region,
which consists of much of southeast Turkey, northeastern Syria, northern Iraq, northwestern Iran,
as well as some other isolated areas
in the former Soviet Union.
Kurdish is the majority language spoken in those areas.
There are approximately 30 million
native speakers of Kurdish.
That includes around 14.5 million in Turkey,
5.6 million in Iraq, 6 million in Iran
and around 2 million in Syria.
It also includes a Kurdish diaspora living outside
of the Kurdistan Region, most notably in Germany.
Like Persian, Kurdish is a member of the Indo-Iranian
branch of the Indo-European language family.
But whereas Persian belongs to the southwestern sub-branch,
Kurdish belongs to the northwestern sub-branch.
Persian and Kurdish share many similarities
but they're not mutually intelligible.
The history of the Kurdish language
is the subject of much speculation.
For much of its history, the Kurdish language
was not a written language.
Folk tales and poetry were passed down orally
from generation to generation.
With few exceptions, the earliest written Kurdish texts
come from the 15th century and later.
There was one known poem from the seventh century,
written in the Gorani dialect.
But technically, the Gorani dialect is actually
a separate language from Kurdish.
Okay, wait! This is getting confusing.
Let me back up for a minute.
What is the Kurdish language? Is it one unified language
that all Kurdish people can understand and speak?
No, not really.
It's a collection of related dialect spread out
across a continuum, meaning that the language
changes gradually over a geographic distance.
There are three main dialect groups of Kurdish:
Kurmanji, Sorani and Pehlewani
The most widely spoken is Kurmanji
with around 20 million native speakers.
It is the major dialect spoken in Turkey as well as
in Syria and some parts of Iraq and parts of Iran.
The second most widely spoken is Sorani, with
6 or 7 million native speakers mainly in Iraq and Iran.
The third most widely spoken is Pehlewani,
which is spoken by about 3 million people in some
Kurdish areas in Iran and one district in Iraqi Kurdistan
These 3 dialects have a relatively low degree
of mutual intelligibility.
So some people consider them to be distinct languages
and not just dialects of one language.
The differences between these dialects have been
compounded by the fact that the Kurds are spread out
across several different countries
and have no central media or school system
and haven't had much interaction with
the other areas of Kurdistan.
And there has also been some influence from the
official languages of the countries where they live.
Kurmanji is written in the Latin alphabet like Turkish,
while Sorani is written in a Perso-Arabic script.
Pehlewani is written in either script.
On top of these main Kurdish dialects, or Kurdish languages depending on how you look at it,
there are also some other languages
spoken by some Kurds
A few million Kurds speak either Zaza or Gorani,
which form a separate sub branch of
the northwestern Iranian languages.
They're still quite closely related to the Kurdish dialects
and since they are spoken by Kurds,
some people consider them to be Kurdish dialects,
for reasons related to cultural and ethnic identity.
Linguistic freedom.
A big part of the story of Kurdish is
the desire for linguistic freedom.
In Turkey the Kurdish language was heavily suppressed
for decades, it was illegal to print Kurdish language materials.
It was a prohibited language in government institutions
and schools and, in public, it was prohibited to speak it.
Even though not everyone followed that rule in public,
that was the rule.
These days, those policies have been relaxed but
Kurds still want certain freedoms like the right to use
the Kurdish language as the language of instruction
in regional schools.
There was a similar situation in Syria and Iraq, where
the language was made illegal and heavily suppressed.
From what I understand, Iran has not aggressively
suppress the Kurdish language
but they have discouraged its use and
promoted assimilation  to the Persian language.
There is one country where Kurdish
is an official language and that is Iraq.
And there is one area where Kurds have official
autonomy and that's in Iraqi Kurdistan which is run
by the kurdish regional government.
There, Kurdish is the language of instruction in schools
and it's used in the media.
Since there are speakers of both Kurmanji and Sorani
dialects in Iraqi Kurdistan, the government promotes
both of them in schools and in the media.
There was now also another de facto autonomous
Kurdish region and that is in Syrian Kurdistan.
It is known as Rojava.
Due to the Civil War, the Syrian government is no longer
in control of the area and all restrictions
on the Kurdish language are now irrelevant.
Schools have introduced a new Kurdish curriculum,
taught in Kurdish.
The form of Kurdish used in Syrian Kurdistan
is Kurmanji.
With Kurdish autonomy and Kurdish language schools
now existing in both Iraq and in Syria,
the Kurdish language might become stronger
and more standardized in the future.
So what exactly is Kurdish like?
Well, that depends on what variety of Kurdish
you're talking about.
So let's take a look at both, Kurmanji
and after that we'll look at Sorani.
Here are a few interesting features of Kurmanji.
Kurmanji nouns are all either masculine or feminine.
And there are four noun cases.
It is generally an SOV language,
though certain sentences are SVO.
Kurmanji has something called ergativity.
Kurmanji has prepositions and postpositions
and it also has something called circumpositions.
Let's have a look at the nouns and their cases first.
Kurmanji has four noun cases:
nominative, oblique, construct and vocative.
The case endings are different, depending
on the gender and number of the noun.
Here's an example with the word for "man"
Now here's an example using the word for "woman"
You may have noticed that the plural case endings
are the same for both genders.
Because in Kurmanji, gender applies only
to singular nouns, not the plural nouns.
Okay, let's look at some example sentences,
including Kurmanji.
Here we'll see that Kurmanji is generally SOV.
This means "I see the men"
So if we translate this sentence directly, it's like:
"I - man - see"
"Ez" equals "I" , "mirov" equals "man"
"an" is the oblique case marker and also
the plural marker. And "dibînim" is "see"
So you can see that the sentence is SOV,
with the object coming in the middle position.
This means "We are Kurdish" or "We are Kurds".
If we try to translate this sentence directly,
it's like "We - Kurds - are"
"Em" equals "we", "kurd" equals "Kurd".
In equals "are", that's the present tense copula.
Again we can see that this is SOV.
This sentence doesn't actually have an object
but it has something called a compliment,
which comes in the same position as the object.
Now, why does the noun in the first sentence have
an ending on it marked in yellow
but in the second sentence there isn't one?
That's because nominative case has no ending
in either singular or plural in Kurmanji.
So we only know, it's plural from the context.
And here the context is that the subject is "we".
So we know it's plural.
Kurmanji exhibit something called ergativity.
In ergative languages, the subject of a verb sometimes
functions as though it's the object of the sentence.
In Kurmanji, this happens when the verb
is in one of the past tenses.
The agent, that is the "doer" of the action,
is in the oblique case like an object.
And the patient, that is the receiver of the action,
is in the nominative case, like a subject.
The verb then takes an ending to agree with the patient.
We would translate this as "I saw him"
But it's more like "By me he was seen".
Literally word for word it's "me he saw"
But the verb ending confirms that
he is actually the receiver of the action.
This means "He saw me" or "By him, I was seen"
Word by word it's : "him I saw"
But again, the verb ending confirms
that "I" is the receiver of the action.
So here "im" is the ending for the first person singular
and that matches the patient of the sentence.
And that's "I" in this case.
I find ergativity quite difficult to wrap my head around.
It's not found in most Indo-European languages.
It's found in Kurdish, it's found in Pashto and it's found
in some of the northern Indian languages.
Okay, if we want to make that last sentence negative,
we simply add a negative prefix to the verb.
This means "he didn't see me". This is an example
of how Kurmanji uses lots of different affixes.
Kurmanji has prepositions which come before nouns,
phrases or pronouns and post positions which come
after nouns, phrases or pronouns.
But it also has circumpositions
which wrap around the noun or pronoun.
Or the entire noun phrase. For example:
this means "in front of"
This means "there's a tree in front of our house".
So if we try to read the sentence word by word, it's:
"in front - house - our - of - tree - there is"
Now, I don't know if "of" is the part that I should have
separated but the point there is that in "front of" is split
into two pieces and surrounds the noun phrase.
Now, let's look at some of those Kurmanji sentences again
and we'll compare them to some Sorani sentences.
Again here are the sentences for "I see the men",
in Kurmanji:
in Sorani:
Now one difference that you can see is that
the preposition is different in the two different languages.
So, in Kurmanji, it's "Ez" that means "I"
but, in Sorani, it's "min".
Why is it "min"?
Well, in Kurmanji "min" is the 1st person singular pronoun
in the oblique case, like an object pronoun,
while "Ez" is the nominative case.
But in Sorani, the pronouns have no cases.
So there's just one word and that word is "min".
Another different word here is "piyawekan",
which is the word for "man" in Sorani.
That's different from the Kurmanji word "mirovan"
I think this is just an alternate word for "man" in Sorani
I think in Sorani the word "mirov" means "man"
more as "a human".
Now both words for men here have the ending "an"
but it's actually different in both languages.
In Kurmanji, its' the oblique case plural marker
but in Sorani, there are no cases.
So, in Sorani, it's just the general plural marker.
Now the sentences for "We are Kurds"
in Kurmanji
and in Sorani:
Now here again, we can see that the pronoun
is different in the two languages.
It's the first person plural pronoun
but, in Kurmanji, it's "em" and in Sorani, it's "êma"
And, in both languages, we have
the present tense copula "in".
The only difference here is the orthography.
In Kurmanji, there's a space before the copula.
Now the sentences for "I saw him",
in Kurmanji:
and in Sorani:
These sentences look quite similar. The Sorani sentence
has an extra "m" attached to the object of the sentence.
That "m" is actually an affix representing the subject "min".
In a Sorani past tense sentence, the subject is
represented as an affix before the verb.
Here the subject is also stated overtly as "min".
But the sentence is possible without that first word.
In Kurmanji, it's not like that.
Now the sentences for "he saw me",
in Kurmanji:
and in Sorani:
This example is similar to the last one.
We can see that the pronouns are different in Sorani
because Sorani has no case distinction.
And we can see that, in Kurmanji, the verb has an ending
that the Sorani verb doesn't have.
In the Kurmanji sentence, an object's suffix
is attached to the end of the verb.
In Sorani, on the other hand,
a subject affix is added before the verb.
And here are the sentences for "He didn't see me",
in Kurmanji:
in Sorani:
Now, this sentence is basically the same
as the last one, except that it's negative.
And we can see that Kurmanji and Sorani
use negation in the same way.
Here are the sentences for
"There's a tree in front of our house",
in Kurmanji:
in Sorani:
In the Kurmanji sentence, we have a circumposition
that wraps around the noun phrase.
But, in the Sorani sentence, there is a preposition
that comes before the noun phrase.
And the preposition is totally different.
And the noun phrase itself is also somewhat different.
"mala" means "house" in Kurmanji,
while "mall" means "house" in Sorani.
And "me" means "our" in Kurmanji
while in Sorani it's "man".
The "ek" after "mall" is an indefinite article
which doesn't exist in Kurmanji.
And the "e" is a connector which also
isn't used in the Kurmanji sentence
So, as you can see, there are some significant
differences between Kurmanji and Sorani.
So, which variety of Kurdish should you learn?
Well, if you're planning on spending some time
in the Kurdistan Region, then it would make sense
to learn the variety of the place where you plan
to spend the most time.
And, in the future, you can always learn to adapt
and speak a different dialect by extension.
Is Kurdish a difficult language to learn?
Well, there are some things like ergativity
that are probably challenging for people
who have never encountered them before.
But, probably, some of the most challenging things
will be the dialectal variation in the language.
And the lack of a single standard language
as well as a general lack of learning materials.
On the other hand, from what I understand,
if you have a previous knowledge of Persian,
that will help you a great deal and learning Kurdish.
And Kurdish people are also all very welcoming
and friendly and very enthusiastic about
helping you to learn their language.
And that kind of support is always very encouraging.
Okay, the question of the day. For Kurdish speakers:
How easy is it for you to communicate
with speakers of other varieties of Kurdish?
And do you consider them all dialects of a single language,
or do you consider them distinct languages?
And for people who studied Kurdish:
What did you find challenging about the language?
And, in general, what was your experience with the language?
We'd like to hear about it in the comments down below.
Definitely be sure to check out Langfocus
on Twitter, on Facebook and on Instagram.
And again, I'd like to say thanks to all of my Patreon
supporters for continuing to make Langfocus possible
Thank you for watching and have a nice day.